JASON DE LORME: Hi.
Welcome to our
session on automating
the modernization of VM-based
applications to containers.
My name's Jason
De Lorme, and I'm
joined by my peer Mike Coleman.
There's three areas
of modernization
that you can consider
when moving applications
to the cloud.
The first is infrastructure
modernization.
And when we think about this
on the axis of complexity
and value, infrastructure
modernization
is by far the easiest step.
As you graduate
through this scale,
complexity increases with
changing code and building
cloud-native applications
all the way up
to process automation.
Moving and adopting
cloud-native technologies
also requires optimizing
DevOps practices
and optimizing your
people and processes.
So really to land those
first few workloads,
we're going to talk to you
today about infrastructure
modernization and some of the
options that you have here.
Often customers go through an
application rationalization
exercise in order to determine
which applications to move
to the cloud in which order.
So the first category
of applications,
often called legacy
applications and sometimes
even referred to as
monolith applications,
that all of the functionality
is into a single binary or one
complicated application.
And monoliths aren't
always a bad thing.
But when they're VM
based, potentially they
take a long time to start.
They load logs.
They load cache.
They don't necessarily
lend themselves
to being able to be replicated
into multiple instances.
We think of these traditionally
as not ready for cloud native.
However, they can be rehosted
into infrastructure VMs,
so moving from on-prem VMs
into a VM in infrastructure
as a service, for example.
The other option is
to start thinking
about maybe decomposing
that monolith,
and reimagining
it, and refactoring
to cloud native services.
The second area are what we
might think of as container
ready.
And this actually might
be bigger than you think.
The options here,
you can clearly
rehost these applications into
an [INAUDIBLE] based approach
with VMs, or you
could replatform them
to something like Kubernetes
and put them in a container,
and have them orchestrated.
This is really going to be the
focus of our talk here today.
As you think about some
of these other container--
cloud-compatible,
or cloud-friendly,
or cloud-native
applications that
might already be in containers,
those are certainly candidates.
We'll dive into
number two today.
So what are containers?
If you've been under a rock
for the last five, six,
seven years, then
you've probably
never heard the term container.
And ultimately they're a method
for packaging up an application
and all of its dependencies.
The most common phrase you
hear related to containers
is it works on my machine,
hence it will work in the cloud.
It will work on
somebody else's machine.
And we often get away from some
of those mysterious dependency
issues or configuration issues
that weren't necessarily
there when you ran it on your
laptop in dev, for example.
Other phrases that we hear often
associated with containers,
things like being lightweight.
Because it doesn't take
the entire operating
system-- it's just your
application and all
the dependencies-- it
becomes more portable.
It's using a standardized
format that can be used.
It helps increase productivity
and ultimately helps
drive security as well.
So why do we do this?
Why do we build containers?
If you think of a traditional
VM-based application,
often choices were made
to put an application
per VM inside of the
customer's infrastructure
because of that bleeding
over of dependencies.
Maybe one application
leverages a shared library
that can get overwritten,
and that can create havoc
for the other application.
We ultimately optimize those
applications for the minimum VM
constraints for the
operating system--
a certain amount of memory,
a certain amount of CPU
and disk--
not based on the application's
requirements itself.
So we often see underutilized
hardware being leveraged
and also a complicated rollout
process for every single VM,
because every single
app has its own VM.
If we can move to a
place where applications
can co-exist and not
step on each other,
and not conflict with
each other in a single VM,
we can get to a
place where we're
optimizing the
infrastructure, optimizing
even the licensing costs
since often the operating
system is licensed at the
VM and not at the container.
If I can get two applications
into a single VM,
I've halved my licensing
costs for that.
Or I can get to high
availability easier
with the same licensing
costs because I
can have two instances of
this application running.
Each VM now has
two instances here.
So I mentioned the
container-based approach.
You can use containers for
Windows or Linux machines.
Now, Windows is a
little bit more recent
when it comes to adopting
containerized strategies.
For that reason there are
a few different behaviors
versus Linux, which was
built from the beginning
to support containers.
There are a handful
of things that you
need to think about when moving
to a containerized environment
in an orchestrator
like Kubernetes.
Specifically, some of
those Windows containers
don't support privileged pods.
That means those things
like virus-scanning software
really live at the VM level.
They don't live inside
the container itself.
Those types of services
need to be examined.
Anything that has low-level
network dependencies, where
it's dependent on something
below layer 7 in the networking
stack, for example,
you don't necessarily
want to depend on the IP
address of another machine
or joining a cluster where
there's a heartbeat in between
and they need to know
a static IP address.
Can be a little problematic
when you think about IPs.
And we can talk about
ways of addressing that.
If there's low-level
GPU or TPU support,
this isn't available in
a Windows container yet.
Cloud-native features like
Istio to create a service mesh
in order to help with traffic
management and service
discovery.
This isn't supported in
Windows containers just yet,
nor is being able to use
something like CloudRun
or Knative, the open source
version where you can steal
the zero in a
serverless environment--
not quite ready for
Windows containers.
So let's talk about
what is ready.
And what are the ideal
container candidates?
So first off, I would look at
your web applications, your web
and logic tiers, things
that-- maybe they're
written in Python, PHP,
Java, ASP.NET, for example,
those things hosted in IIS.
Those are great
candidates potentially
to run inside of a container
in a container-orchestrated
environment like Kubernetes.
Another area to look at is batch
jobs or console applications
that may be running
spiky workloads,
things that run maybe
every day at 6:00 PM
or things that run and
listen to queues that don't
have any kind of GUI to them.
They're an ideal candidate.
Even Windows Services,
those are applications
that are registered with
the Windows operating system
to begin at startup,
for example.
They may even log to the
Windows application event log.
All these things can be
containerized and run
in a container orchestrator.
Now let me jump to the lower
right-hand side of this
and talk about those
container workloads that
are potentially unsuitable.
And I'm going to
start right away.
I mentioned GUI, the
graphical user interface.
Anything that has
a GUI is not going
to be a good candidate
for a container.
You can't run a remote desktop
protocol session, for example,
into a container.
So virtualized desktop
infrastructure, VDI,
for example, is not
a fit for containers.
If the application
you're using is primarily
centered around user interaction
through a Win32 console,
for example, that
is not something
that's going to run
inside of a container.
Now, there's a
gray area of things
that you may want to investigate
further and use a fit
assessment tool, for example,
to determine whether it's
appropriate for running in a
container-- things on the Linux
side where there's a GPU or
TPU dependency, areas where
the container requires
elevated privileges.
Another big category here
is commercial off-the-shelf
software, or COTS.
Now, most ISVs have come
out with newer versions
of their applications that
are containerized already.
So it's often a good fit to
think about maybe a version
upgrade that will take you to
their container-based approach.
However, there are a
lot of applications
where maybe the vendor
is no longer in business,
or maybe it's critical
to the business,
but nobody really knows what
the application was written in.
You just have the binaries.
You don't have access
to the source code.
They could be a fit.
However, we should run
an assessment tool here
in order to determine whether
or not it will work well
in a containerized environment.
And with that I'd like to
introduce my peer Mike Coleman,
who can talk to you
about a solution
that we have at Google
to help you with this.
Mike?
MIKE COLEMAN: Thanks, Jason.
I want to talk to you
today about a tool called
Migrate for Anthos and GKE.
We built this tool
to help automate
the migration of virtual
machine-based workloads
from environments like Amazon,
AWS, VMWare, Azure, and even
Google Cloud Compute Engine.
This tool automatically
inspects those container--
those virtual machines--
excuse me-- and convert them
to containers where then you can
start taking advantage of some
of the benefits that Jason
mentioned previously, things
like improved resource
utilization, unified logging
and monitoring, and then
potentially day 2 operations.
So it's one thing to
talk about a tool.
It's another thing
to actually show it.
So I want to do a
quick demo where
I'm going to take
you through a payment
service-based virtual
machine migration.
So I have an online
boutique, an online shopping,
and a bunch of the services are
already running in containers.
So think of the front
end, the shopping
cart, some of those services.
They call back to
a payment service
that's running in a virtual
machine on Google Cloud.
We're going to migrate
that VM into a container
and integrate it with the
rest of the application.
We'll start with
the fit assessment.
As Jason mentioned, it's
critical to understand
how well your VM-based workload
can run in a container.
From there we're going to
create a migration plan.
We'll make a few tweaks to that.
We'll run the migration.
We'll get a set of
deployment artifacts.
We'll deploy those.
And then finally, we'll
edit the service discovery
so that it's not looking for
the virtual machine, but rather
the payment service running
as a Kubernetes service.
This is the VM that we're
going to migrate today
into a container
running on Kubernetes.
So let's go ahead.
I'm going to go up here and
close this down because we
don't need it anymore.
And let's take a look at this
application actually running.
So if I come over
here and I click
on one of the products,
the antique camera,
I click Add to Cart,
and then I click
Place Order, everything's
working as expected.
That order was processed
using the payment service
on the virtual machine.
So the first thing we need to do
to get this all working though
is to stop the
payment service VM.
A virtual machine can't be
migrated until it's stopped.
With the VM stopped, let's go
ahead and clear the screen,
and close out of Cloud Shell.
Now let's take a look at the
migration fit assessment.
I've created a report
by running an agent
on the virtual machine, and it's
stored here in this JSON file.
I can upload this in
the Cloud Console,
and it's going to give me an
indication that my application
is a good fit for migration.
If I want to drill down,
I can click on the name
and get a list of all
the different things that
were inspected.
We know that we're
good to go here,
so why don't we go ahead
and close out of this
and actually start
the migration?
I'm going to go
over here, and I'm
going to click on
Migrations, and I'm going
to click Create Migration.
I'm going to give
my migration a name.
I'm going to call it
online boutique migration.
We'll choose our source.
The instance name was
payment service VM.
And we're going to
just do the image.
So let's create the migration.
In the interest of
time I've sped this up
so we can move on to our
next step, which is to review
and edit the migration plan.
So the migration plan comes
up, and the first thing
I want to do is
add an annotation
to tell Migrate for GKE to
create an image that can
run on an autopilot cluster.
I also want to go and adjust the
image name and the Kubernetes
service name and deployment
name to payment service instead
of payment service VMs since
we're not running in a VM
any longer.
So this takes a few minutes.
I've sped the video up.
I'll rejoin you
when it's finished.
With the process completed,
let's take a look
at the artifacts
that were created.
So I've come down
here under Next Steps.
I click Options and
Review Artifacts.
And that will bring up a list
of what was created for us.
The first thing you'll
see are a couple
of Docker images one
that will actually deploy
and one we can use
for day 2 operations.
We also get a Dockerfile and
a Kubernetes deployment spec.
So if I open up
Cloud Shell, you'll
see that I've already
downloaded these files.
So I'll do an LS here.
You can see all the files.
Now, this Kubernetes
deployment_spec.yaml is going
to create a new
Kubernetes deployment,
and it's going to create
a new Kubernetes service
for our migrated workloads.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Let's make sure
everything's started.
We'll take a look
at the service.
And there it is running.
And let's take a
look at the pod.
And it's running as well.
So what we're going to do now
is check on our application.
Now, actually, I
expect this to fail.
So let's come in here.
Let's click on the typewriter.
And let's go ahead and add that
to our cart, and check out.
So it's in our cart.
Place order.
Now, what happened
is it's trying
to reach the payment service
on the DNS name of the VM.
So what we need
to do is actually
modify the deployment
spec for our application.
And we need to change it from
looking at the internal DNS
name of the VM to the
Kubernetes service name.
So that's payment service.
So we'll chop off the DNS
name here and just leave
payment service.
We'll save that out.
And then we can go back in and
rerun that deployment YAML.
And that's going to
reprovision our services.
So let's go ahead and do that.
We'll do a kubectl apply and
apply that updated boutique
deployment.yaml.
It'll reconfigure the services.
So let's go ahead and
clear the screen here.
Let's look at the pods.
It looks like the checkout
service has been reconfigured
and is running.
So if I come in here and
I click on the typewriter,
and I add it to cart,
and I place order,
everything is
working as expected.
We've successfully migrated
our payment service
from a virtual machine
into a container
running on a GKE autopilot
cluster using Migrate for GKE.
So that's the demo.
And demos are great.
They give you a feel
for the product,
and you can see some of
the things in action.
But it's important also to
look at how the tool's used
in the real world.
So I want to start by
discussing a customer example.
This is The Telegraph.
They're a content management,
content publication service
over in the UK.
And they had a legacy
content management system
that they were running.
It was super important
to their business,
but it was a little
difficult for them
to manually migrate
it into containers.
So they used Migrate for Anthos
to do that work for them--
vastly simplified the process.
And they're already
realizing savings,
not just on the infrastructure
as Jason mentioned before
with the bin
packing and whatnot,
but also in the day-to-day
operation of that CMS.
So that's one customer.
That's one example.
Now, what about yourself?
Now, if you're going
to look at migrating,
there's some things I
want you to consider.
These are six items.
They're not insurmountable by
any stretch of the imagination.
They're really presented
here just as things for you
to be aware of.
And the first we
saw in the demo.
We were using VM-based
DNS hostname discovery.
So we had the DNS name
of that payment service.
We converted that to
a Kubernetes service.
So we let Kubernetes take care
of that service discovery using
its own internal DNS structure.
Along those same lines,
if you have host files
that you've customized
and you've got hostnames,
you can use host aliases in the
pod spec to take care of that.
So that's another
simple migration.
Again, looking at the
pod YAML, a couple
other things we could take
care of are file shares.
So file shares are great.
You can use them.
We just don't automatically
migrate them for you.
You're going to need to define
NFS persistent volumes inside
of the pod spec to
take care of those.
And the same with
environment variables.
You may be using an
environment variable
for the URI for your
database, for instance.
You can actually define that
same environment variable
in the pod spec,
and then you don't
need to change any other
applications because you're
getting the same information
you're expecting.
So find the environment
variable in the pod YAML,
and that'll take care of that.
Now, I want to say something--
and I might say it
kind of forcefully
because I really believe it--
just because you're migrating
something to a container
doesn't mean that you don't
have to understand how it works
and how it runs.
And matter of fact, if you want
to have a successful migration,
it's critical that you
understand what you have
and how it works.
When you go in and you
look at a migration,
you should be looking at the
services and the agents that
are running in that VM and
make a conscious decision on
whether or not you need
them in your container.
For instance, you
may have an agent
running that's doing
logging and monitoring.
And we'll talk about
that in a little bit
in the next bulletpoint, but you
probably want to disable that.
You also want to
make sure you're
running at the right run level.
So go through, audit
those services.
Disable the ones you don't need.
That will help minimize
container image size,
and improve performance,
and reduce complexity.
So this is a really
important one
that I want you to go through.
The other thing that's
not specifically
called out here along the same
vein, file system structure.
Are there directories
and files that you don't
need in the resulting image?
You can tell Migrate
for Anthos and Migrate
for GKE to not include certain
directories, certain files.
Again, smaller image
size, better performance.
And then finally--
I alluded to it--
application logging.
We integrate Migrate for
Anthos and Migrate for GKE
with the cloud, Google
Cloud metrics, logging,
and monitoring services.
So you don't actually
need to have those agents.
You don't need to do that
work in the container.
We'll just pick that
stuff up for you,
and you can monitor
it in Cloud Console
right there within Google Cloud.
So that's what we
have for you today.
I really want to thank you
for tuning in on behalf
of myself and Jason.
Why don't you go out, have
a great rest of your day,
and look at migrating some
of those VM workloads?